Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg spent
another action-packed day on Capitol
Hill today this time taking questions
from members of the House Energy and
Commerce Committee during the hearings
Ucker Berg was pressed on whether
Facebook's content decisions amount to
political censorship I'd like to ask you
do you subjectively manipulate your
algorithms to prioritize or censor
speech
congresswoman we don't think about what
we're doing a censoring speech I think
that there are there are types of
content like terrorism that I think that
we all agree we do not want to have on
our service so we build systems that can
identify those and can remove that
content and we're very proud of that
work let me tell you something right now
I dominant silk is not terrorism notice
he didn't deny censoring speech because
of course Facebook does it all the time
and here's an example
Eric Nesbitt is a Republican candidate
for state Senate in the state of
Michigan his online campaign
announcement was recently rejected by
Facebook for containing what they called
shocking and disrespectful material
Facebook now says that rejection was a
mistake now they've been called on it
Eric Nesbitt joins us tonight to explain
Eric thanks for coming on so what
exactly about your announcement was
determined by Facebook where its famous
algorithm as disrespectful or shocking
still trying to figure that out it was
just announcing my candidacy for the
state Senate last week here in West
Michigan and I talked about limiting
government lowering taxes lowering our
auto insurance rate and defending the
unborn and protecting our Second
Amendment rights and visiting my website
vote Nesbitt calm that's all I was going
for and I think when you got to
defending the unborn and protecting the
Second Amendment you know that gets to
Facebook if you live in Menlo Park
that's not shocking well maybe banning
sanctuary cities and I did have a
picture of a few veterans that I was
talking to also so I mean I and so I
announced it last week and I wanted to
boost the ad on on Friday and I started
to put that boost in and it usually
takes a few hours for them to approve it
he got back home around 6 o'clock on
Friday night and that's when they sent
me that message saying that you're not
following our advertising policies
and I was kind of taken aback because I
was going to spend a few hundred dollars
trying to get knowing a little better
and two counties north where I live in
Allegan County and up in Kent County and
Kent wooden gains yeah and I figured
well I'll ask my facebook audience
whether Facebook's is censoring that
conservative thought and I think the the
answer came pretty you know was it was
pretty open from my followers so
Facebook says it's a mistake do you
think this had the kind of thing happens
equally to Democrats running for state
Senate seats in Michigan I I haven't I
haven't heard of anything on this
nationally or other places I mean I have
a good conservative record and in the
house I was named by Hillsdale College
as the alumnus a year for being a
conservative reformer and so I continue
to get out there but it's frustrating
when you're running a modern campaign
you've got to be on social media you
have to be on the Internet to be able to
broadcast and if it in any company knows
whether they've been the target of a
Twitter storm or on Facebook any company
knows you got to respond quickly yes and
if this means that it takes 24-48 hours
or 72 hours for a conservative to
respond but liberals are able to respond
very quickly then I think that's very
troubling I think senator Cruz really
hit the nail on its head yesterday
during the hearing congressman Walberg
went after it today and so did fred
Upton yeah it's it's a massive amount of
power for social control we should be
worried Eric thank you for joining us so
had a Grand Rapids great thanks for
having me